[Music]
the philippine coast guard says it
received a distressed call around 6 a.m
on monday
a naval vessel called mv mircraft ii
carrying more than 130 people had caught
fire near the waters of rizal kazan
province north of the philippines
and by midday more than a hundred people
were rescued including eight of the
boat's crew members
some of those injured were taken to
hospital
the fire has been put out
but authorities are also checking for
traces of oil spill
initially
they said that
the fire started at the engine room
but will try to get to the bottom of it
we have accounted all the passengers
including the crew
we have stopped already the search and
rescue operations
and we just
probably proceed to the
investigation this company has another
incident in sometime in 2017.
at least six other vessels helped the
coast guards search and rescue
operations
the vessel is being towed towards baluti
island in 2017 another vessel owned by
the same company was carrying more than
250 passengers when it cup sized in the
same region
five people were killed
the philippines is an archipelago of
more than seven thousand islands often
battered by frequent storms and poor
enforcement of safety rules which have
led to several maritime disasters in
recent years
jamal
al jazeera manila